[Music]
that's what we're talking about what
time we get up in the morning and
say we smile okay before we go we're
hearing from a 13 year old who made an
emotional speech you're going to
remember this speech at the democratic
national convention
about how president-elect joe biden
helped helped him
with his stutter here's what he said
back in august
he told me about a book of poems
by yates he would read out loud to
practice
he showed me how he marks his addresses
to make them easier to say out loud
so i did the same thing today that is
braden harrington and he said the former
vice president gave him the confidence
not to shy away from his starter you'll
recall mr biden also stuttered as a
child
harrington and his parents spoke to our
maria viral about what mr biden's win
means to them
i see him as a role model he stutters
and he made it like
this far in life as a president-elect
and that's
really i would say brave of him to
put himself out there for the whole
country
and to be a leader
and that's just really great of him to
just
push himself how does it make you feel
knowing that braden's voice
was heard and respected um at a very
pivotal moment in our country
that's very emotional for me too
i think for all of us we're very proud
of him i think
what we've been given has been a gift
and a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
we actually got to see firsthand what
our
student to be president of the united
states is like as a normal human being
and he had a huge impact on our family
braden has more confidence and there's
less stress with what's going on
do you have aspirations one day to
follow in his footsteps
i don't know i have days where i'm like
oh i want to be president and i have
days where i'm like
i won't make a day
braden's doing really well he's doing
great he's doing really well such a nice
it was so nice when they highlighted him
and
the biden campaign consults with me
about nothing but i'll bet braden if
there is inauguration will be invited
that's my prediction great gesture